previously on TV sins did they give you
an evil problem what's up with anal
probing I mean aliens travel billions of
light-years just to check out a boy move
[Music]
Calendar II space it seems to go on and
on forever
but then you get to the end and the
gorilla starts throwing barrels at you
exchange barrels with decorative pillows
and that is exactly how my college
girlfriend described our first time
having sex also what a dump game I've
always hated gorillas throwing barrels
because gorillas somehow has one and
learn two L's when barrel has two R's
and one out correct English Spelling's
are heard hey fry pizza going out come
back who knew that sam raimi ripped off
the Futurama pilot for his opening -
spider-man - the judge emic judge ursins
sitting at Table two you were drinking
wine right next to an arcade game called
monkey fracas junior glass house much
I've spent three minutes wondering if
this flesh colored mitten was a strange
Anatomy oversight and now I can't get
that time back
active cryogenic equipment left unmanned
and an unlocked room is believable
opening the style door without using
your ass cheek or elbow to trigger the
handle is unfathomable I always thought
by this point in my life I'd be the one
making the crank calls is there a point
in which someone achieves crank-call
status I thought the qualification was
having a phone and knowing how to dial
anonymously here's to another lousy
millennium wrong since there was no Year
Zero the millennium didn't actually
start until 2001 unless of course you're
just saying someone's getting ready to
play that phone Robbie Williams track
again then carry on obviously it
wouldn't be midnight and all these
places at the same time but what I'm
saying is on a technologically advanced
planet we should have done away with
time zones a long time ago it's called
Universal Time it's absolutely brilliant
and we will never do it because humans
hate change
so really this is a sin for all of us
damn it at least get the positioning of
the earth right how is it supposed to be
midnight in New York City when the Sun
just rose in LA it's like noon there
according to this seriously this is
literally as far away as New York could
get from midnight as possible they want
us to think fry falls backward into a
cryogenic chamber however given where
the chair landed fry successfully
executed a backward vertical vault
somersault without spilling his drink
and that is severely under play note to
future cryogenics experts the
automatically setting cryo timeframe of
1,000 years may lack a bit of wisdom
aliens destroy New York not
once but twice and decide to spare the
applied cryogenics building good to know
plot convenience isn't just an earth
thing also New York power plants would
have been destroyed so how are the cryo
chambers even keeping cool also also
during the re medieval times this
building would have stood as a worship
worthy monolith to be explored and
revered anyone emerging from a cryopod
during those years would have been
considered a god-like being and shape
the future where is that story great is
this where disenchantment comes from New
York drivers have a nice future these
guys are surprisingly casual considering
for I used to chamber without permission
or pay good afternoon sir
yeah I'm no expert on cryogenic reentry
protocol but having a human do the
initial eval and explanation about
aliens living among us might smooth
things out right probes often cause
unexpected secretion spatter so her use
of protective eye gears to be applauded
she forgot to cover her mouth that might
probe you Layton friends is disturbing
and unsanitary how does this freezer
keep turning its own knob when someone
gets thrown into it I hear if you turn
your oh not too much you go blind you've
got to the count of five to let me out
of here why would a society with three
fingers and one thumb use the same good
thing these technologically advanced
cryogenic chambers operate just like a
toaster oven
so fry can help Leela out also I'm glad
for I decided not to be a dick and leave
it set to 1,000 but did he have to go
back to only five minutes she'd be fine
after a day right even an hour you might
as well just set it to the automatic let
her out quickly so the shenanigans can
continue setting standards and practices
since everyone seems to move through
these tubes at different speeds and come
from different locations
how do people not hit each other all the
time at the very least there would be
human centipede traffic jams constantly
civilization has been rebuilt twice and
quarters still exist where did the dead
people go we saw a few go into the
suicide booth but not come out for a
booth that stabs hacks and electrocute
people it is lacking in discarded parts
and leftover gooey bits and you know
what deceased people shoot is the most
effective way to eliminate bodies so how
are bender and fry not riding down a
horror slide right now America's
favourite suicide boot since 2008 that's
funny as hell but the show seems to keep
forgetting how New York City's been
destroyed twice since 1999 and would
therefore have no way of keeping any
kind of nefarious business running that
long oh no it's the Cyclops
look don't look I could easily point out
how convenient Leland is convenient but
instead I think I'll try to figure out
how they're in a bar on New Year's Eve
in New York there isn't packed to the
gills we
share our wisdom with those who seek it
it's a life of quiet dignity also it
allows the show from 1999 to make
relevant pop-culture references even
though the show is set in the year 3000
dating time this feeding time joke
brings up so many questions about these
head cases why would the heads need to
eat with no stomach out of the nutrients
get into the blood how does the blood
flow through to the brain where does the
oxygen come from
how can they be heard so clearly
underwater and most importantly if you
present one as a gift does that mean
you're getting head you gotta love how
this show finds a way to put - Grover
Cleveland heads here
it makes no logical sense but great
comic logical sense and I remove a sin
for it except some of these presidents
why would you bother digging them up to
put their heads in jars does anyone
really want Andrew Jackson's head
spouting out any kind of wisdom you just
made my list bad Richard Nixon
impression in a comedy cliche they ran
into the Hall of criminals but found a
dead end
is this a deep metaphor or does the word
Hall mean something different in the
future also why go through all the
trouble preserving criminals and not
label them if someone programmed you to
jump off a bridge would you do it I have
to check my program there's plenty of
reasons to subtract sins here the
incredible voice work the hilarious
jokes but I'm going with the fact that
like the Simpsons before this show is at
its best when it gets its hard-on and
this episode's consistent theme of
choosing your own purpose is exactly the
kind of heart on I'm talking about
bender can also apparently bend the
space-time continuum because somehow
we've gone back to a time where those
bars behind him are still in place what
is this it's decaying ruins of all New
York a cutscene from AI artificial
intelligence somehow makes its way into
this episode Rockefeller Center
Comcast building Comcast my god she's
gone everyone I ever knew or cared about
is God
I've got no home no family no friends I
want to feel for you fry but just hours
ago when you realized everyone was gone
you exclaimed oh you turned like this
can only mean one thing
impending cycloptic emotional connection
I understand is that it my parents
abandoned me here as a baby and I don't
even know what galaxy they were from
baby I'm the only one I'd alien on this
whole planet you're the only one on that
alien - Leela wait I don't want to spoil
the party but we're all job deserters
now Lily just met bender so how would
she know that bender is also a job
deserter that solves the mystery of the
missing ring this calls for a drink this
doesn't solve the mystery of why bender
was drinking differently here than he
was at the bar we're unemployed but we
doddering old relative de muchas of
millenials hello I'm dick clark's head
ah 1999 show that is blissfully unaware
of Ryan Seacrest and therefore that your
3000 is blissfully unaware - for making
me imagine this world and making me sad
like those people who got upset about
Pandora not being real I'm giving this a
sip but it's an honorary sin removal
we're just adding one this time wait a
minute they repaired his jar rather than
putting him in a new one remember that
leo is just a cartoon remember that
Lilly is just a cartoon remember that if
they try to take off give him an
ass-full amazing pop quiz ass full of
laser was also a the short-lived laser
tag business I started be where my
college girlfriend went for hair removal
see what happened when my LASIK surgery
went very very wrong or D the name of
the death metal cuddle core hybrid band
I managed in the fourth grade no crow
alright what happened to the old crew
perhaps the better question is where
bender found this space cigar sure we
can assume it came from his stomach
cabinet which access some sort of bag of
holding but it is far more likely that
this is a couch cigar and believe me you
should never smoke anything you find
from the cushions of a couch let alone a
space couch you're welcome episode does
not contain a Zoidberg think so no it's
the Cyclops feel it you're a dick
okay there's an old Balkan proverb only
Nixon can go to China come on bender you
can do it and over there is my
intergalactic spaceship